many of those who do escape the horrors
of afghanistan will probably end up here
what's known as little kabul in san
francisco's bay area perhaps the largest
afghan enclave in the west
the sultani family have already made it
here but they worry about those still
trying hopefully
my other friends and the the whom left
behind they could get out soon
it's a sentiment everyone shares here
where it seems they all know someone
who's trying to get out and in the
anxiety there's visible anger muhammad
was a linguist for the afghan government
i didn't sleep for two nights because my
my family is over there
nobody there is no word i can tell you
guys my my pin his parents he says were
assaulted as they tried to reach kabul
airport the taliban beat my mom when
my brother sent me those pictures it
made me cry in
here why why why the u.s has turned
their back to afghan people like this
it's a question they all ask in a
community feeling the uncertainty and
desperate for good news every day
there's a phone call they're scared for
that one certain phone call saying oh
i'm sorry
like they couldn't make it or i'm sorry
this happened it's just that
that one phone call can change anyone's
life
for the chaos in their country they
blame the last u.s president and the
current one democrats like the first
afghan american woman ever elected to
public office here though this is
happening on joe biden's watch
do you think joe biden got this wrong
i think president biden um
played the cards he was dealt
of course we can discuss the who what
when where and why
um but now is not the time this is not a
left or right issue it's a humanitarian
crisis
we also need to understand that a lot
more can be done right now
i think the president is responsible for
every action he you know decides
[Music]
it was after the soviet invasion that
afghans first came to settle here the
mountains said to be a reminder of home
now they fear many of the next
generation desperate for their own
freedoms won't get that chance greg
milam sky news california